we go out every single day of our lives
and sacrifice the time
in order to be average at anything you
know i know you don't wake up i know no
one here on this call wakes up to be
average at anything that they do
and we look very average you know and we
have the talent
that the eye test presents that we
should be dominating
uh you know we have the experience in
terms of some of our guys that have been
through certain things circumstances to
be able to battle through
and we're dealing with a lot of the
reality that we're putting this together
on the fly like
we we are the team that the nba put the
most games on
we're the team that gets someone taken
out during covet during the games
where the team that has to deal with the
refs we're the team that
is literally battling against so many
odds
that at this point is it's not even a
reason to continue to comment on they
are what they are
and as a warrior that i am and that the
energy that i have
alongside my teammates we just have to
turn that corner and we haven't done it
yet but we will
and i'm telling you the league's going
to be on notice when happening so
just got to take it day by day
[Laughter]
i love it michael smith
you know i you know i my memory is not
what it used to be
not a lot of things going on mike got a
lot of things going i'm trying to be a
good husband trying to be a good dad
you know i got things
but was it last week i i think it may
have been on a show called brother from
another
last week all good just a week ago i
think it was somebody
who spends a lot of time in your mirror
somebody
said to me people like you wagging
finger it was a very long
wagging finger about the brooklyn nets
and all these great stats and their
offensive rating
and oh wow they do this and
oh wow look look at james harden and
and nobody has to uh defer nobody has to
take away from their games and oh
the brooklyn nets kyrie irving said
they're very
very average now if he had stopped there
i would say you know that's pretty good
it's pretty good assessment
but then we get the whole string of
excuses
now the nba is out to get him
everybody's out to get me bro the
officials are against that
that covert thing from friday night was
crazy with kd that was crazy okay
come on now like all right he's playing
we're talking about the schedule now
mike the schedule
yeah you got too many games against the
practice the schedule
yeah and you know we had to do this on
the fly
like tell me something the brooklyn nets
have had to do that nobody else has had
to deal with
in these coveted times they do have
talent i agree with
part of the statements i agree with the
random parts of his statement
i think they have the talent i think
they have the experience i don't think
they have what it takes to be a
championship team they're not built
to be a championship team they're built
to be an entertaining
nba team you'll get your money's worth
with brooklyn
on the court and off they're
entertaining on the court
they say stuff they say stuff off the
court
but i don't think they are connect his
hat said disconnected
i think the problem is that they're not
connected and i still need evidence that
they respect
and listen to and apply the insights
of their rookie head coach and he may
not even be the man for the job i don't
know
i think he might be a good coach he may
not be a good coach for this team steve
nash
but i have no i have no doubts about
i have no doubts that they are not a
championship team i do know who a
championship team is we'll talk about
them in a little bit but
i just kind of wanted i want to sit here
and bathe
wait wait wait wait wait wait one second
one second i just wanna make sure i
heard that right
i have no doubts that they are not a
championship team
they're not championship got it they're
not got it okay just want to make sure
okay you'll not win and i figured this
will never and you've been consistent
you've been let me say it even more
since the brain can be even more
consistent
go ahead more emphatic what more in fact
go for it double down they're not coming
because
because one thing it could be like all
right they're not a championship team
that means they're losing seven games to
the lakers in the nba finals
they're not getting to the nba finals
they will not get to the nba finals and
they'll be fortunate
if they reach the conference finals
i see this team oh i can see this team
i could i could rebut i could rebut the
nets
but i'm gonna give i'm gonna touch pass
it back to you and i'm gonna say okay
who is
who you like coming out of the east oh
god like a rebut your next argument i'm
i'm
i'ma just ask you to continue on this
track that you're on right now and i
maybe i'll come back to the next but go
ahead
uh with my my very only risky thing i'm
gonna say about the only
only risk involved with the philadelphia
76ers of my take here
is my very liberal use of philadelphia
slang
john don't do it see that there don't do
it i got it
don't die that's it i just put in the
feed but i'm not about to use it in the
sentence
but i did okay this john will win the
east uh philadelphia 76ers
i i like this team and not just because
of their uh eastern conference leading
record eastern conference best record
this is what happens with uh doc rivers
teams
especially in those early years those
first couple of years
teams just by like if you've never been
coached by doc rivers
he just gets you to buy into him
and he gets that buy-in very quickly
and so that's one part of it and then if
you happen to have a great player which
philadelphia does
that great player usually has some kind
of mind meld
with doc rivers and they take their
already
excellent game to another level he has
done that
yeah he did that in in la with the
clippers they didn't win
but he did that when he first got there
with chris paul blake griffin uh
and deandre jordan they went to another
level they didn't get to the
ultimate level but they went up when he
got to boston they got kg
and paul pierce and ray allen they went
to a championship level
they won it all yeah he's doing that
right now joel embiid
i would love to know the story of the
inside story because embiid has always
been a baller as you said what do you
call him the punisher
he's always no longer the process he's
the punisher now yeah he's the punisher
but he is
punishing consistently and it's just
efficient and he's got he gets embiid he
gets him
he gets him a night off when he needs it
he doesn't push him too much
he just understands that this team how
this team needs to operate it's not
hey embiid is equal with with ben
simmons and tobias harris no
this is embiid is the centerpiece and
everybody else kind of flows around and
circulates around that satellite that is
embiid
i'm telling you they have figured it out
they're a well-coached team they're a
well-constructed team all of a sudden
this is the team that will win the east
the philadelphia 76ers
will win the eastern conference
okay as we sit here uh at this moment
hard to argue with you uh and i wouldn't
argue with you
if there was a legitimate argument
because i agree with you about the
sixers that
i i you're preaching to the converted
when it comes to the sixers
uh i've been waiting for this day for
the culmination and fulfillment
they haven't got a championship yet but
close they look championship ready
uh of the process yes i do want to just
say there's one thing about the nets
everything you said is okay everything
you said i mean well not the predictions
but in terms of
your observations with the exception i
don't think this is a coaching thing
i don't think this is a schematic thing
um
okay no no no no it's not it i i think
it's what steve nash
talked about last night i think it's as
simple as effort
now let's be fair i know we're not in
the business of being fair
sure we are we are about a small sample
size well no i mean as
an industry and as a i mean like hot
takes by their nature
are in the moment and not fair they're
emotional based on
recency bias no different than i went
off the deep end when they beat the
clippers
i get it i get you coming back and being
like see i told you they were frauds
because that's what they look like right
now
and that speaks to that inconsistency
the the the defense listen at this after
losing to the pistons
they've been outscored in the 13 games
they've played since trading with james
harden of the league's worst
defense they're 27 in defense this year
but it gets better or worse
depending on your perspective before
trading for james harden
they had a defensive rating of 109.3
that was 13th
and right now that would rank fifth
109.3
defensive efficiency since the hardened
trade
the defensive rating has been 119 which
is 27th over the past month and that
would be 30th for the entire season
those stats per cleaning the glass so
this just
in the defense is bad part of it is
they're not a good defensive team
oh i'm enjoying it but most of it i
think michael and this is what they
this is what we saw glimpses of we saw
michael
you can't take away who they've beaten
they've beaten some good teams
they had and they beat him with effort
on defense
they're not going to be stoppers lego
mini league defensive team with effort
and i i think what you've seen lately
for whatever reason is lapses
or general disregard or disinterest in
effort on defense
pride as steve nash talked about all
i'll say about the nets is this mike i'm
not making excuses for them
and it's hard to see them coming out of
the east yeah you got no
you can't make excuses for them you know
why you can't make excuses for them
there are no excuses because they've
taken them
all they have taken them all they have
hornets pieces all right i can't create
any new ones
damn i don't know the only thing i want
to point out
is that they played six games together
those
the big their big three has played six
games together that's the only thing
it's a small sample size yeah and
there's time for them to figure it out
all f all we knew michael we look
and i don't want to and what i want to
stop doing what i want to stop myself
from doing
okay is which every week making grand
proclamations on the net
i'll give you credit you've been
consistent you've been consistent you
make consistent that you don't believe
in this team
so this isn't you think this is me thing
i'm saying entertainment week i'm not
gonna go
i'll stick by them they're entertaining
and you said that you said that you said
that
i am not going to go from one week
saying see
i told you so to yeah you right they
suck i'm not gonna do that
okay they need time to figure it out
just like the heels did
just like the warriors did to some
extent and one thing we agreed on at the
beginning was that there was a
this point was going to come this might
be this might not even be the low point
they were going to have to deal with
adversity how would they deal with it
what would be their nine and eight and
i'm referencing the heat's record when
they first got there i got you together
i'm right there
will be there nine and eight maybe it's
now
maybe it's later i don't know but i'm
not gonna sit up here and declare what
they are i'll leave that to you mr hot
take
i'm not gonna declare what they are nor
what they cannot be
when they've only played six games
together but that's very good i would
say this maybe they are whoever
um i've always i've always been uh
been amused by when people say it's
trash talking when they
when they say he's a big trash talker
but when they what the person is saying
is truth
it's not really trash if you're speaking
the truth it's not really a
hot tape right if that's just
i can tell you why if i can tell you why
it's going to happen
all right look at it this way
defense shocking defense is the weakness
right now of the brooklyn nets well
let's see who are the three best players
kyrie irving james harden
and kevin durant the three best players
in no particular order
defender one of those three guys one
could be one
of them when he wants to one is a good
defender one is a good defender
that's it the other one harden harden
can defend when he wants to
he doesn't want he wants to carden can
defend but he doesn't what
not often enough he doesn't give us a
good time all right
so so he's a enough that's one good
defender but
let me let's go to the coaching staff
because you say hey give me effort and
all that stuff steve nash
what's he know about defense okay all
right so now we go
okay so now we go back to steve nash as
a player all right now you're going to
tell me what happened
i'm looking at the coaching mvp
i'm going to the team i know well we got
steve we got great dead tony
that's not fair they don't value it
they don't value it that's why this is
not going to happen why why would they
why would mike antony at this point well
let me ask a question why would
why would mike d'antoni assistant coach
i got it
why would he start to value defense at
this point he's like 70 years old right
i mean you can change but why would he
why not
i guess why would i have a steve madden
but i think it's i think
he's a hall of famers
why would he start no it's defense i got
you it's it's
it's part personality but i think i
think it's very it's personnel too
they need help i don't know if it's the
buyout market i don't know how they need
help
um i do want to touch on more nba team
before we go to break
let me go one more let me get one more
thought on that help though
yeah i'll tell you where their help is
they help us their help is in cleveland
because we make this big trade
everybody's excited biggest biggest
trade in nba history
and and what they lost some really good
players
uh in that deal now one of them tori and
prince had a contract they didn't like
that contract that got it good player
uh made the contract a little too big
but taurean prince gone good player
carol silver gone jared allen those are
good players
that's where their help is hey thanks
for watching brother from another on
youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m peacock appreciate you